[Music]
you do impressions of paper impression
vice put you make impression vice
president of Biden you of course you did
Mitt Romney impressions and then because
of these political impressions you were
invited on Meet the Press yeah which is
one of America's most serious sober
analytical political talk show anymore
that go that was I mean I don't know
because I didn't I didn't watch it
because I don't want I don't want the
that that showed a you know fall in and
you know and its quality in my mind they
had myself and Fred Armisen on their
David Gregory who hosts it yeah asked us
questions about our point of view of
politics and and what what we think make
these these politicians click and I'm
like I'm an idiot
like I'm I literally dropped out of
Community College you do not don't ask
me ask a newspaper editor or a pundit or
or something and and yet because you can
sort of talk like these these these
people they sometimes think that what we
know more than we do and I'm here to
tell you we don't you have you came up
with a key into doing Mitt Romney
impression what was the key it was sort
of something it you thought about what
he sounded like yeah well there are two
things for me with with Mitt Romney uh
one of which is that he has a very
similar tone in my in my mind to George
Clooney like that they both have great
like kind of like radio voices you know
that they're kind of like back in the
throat now mind you I know that the
politics of Mitt Romney and the politics
of George Clooney are very very
different and they they they use their
instruments in different ways kind of
like how you know Nickelback and the
Black Keys play the same instruments but
they use them in very different ways
right I know that but now that was one
thing that I that I that I know it's
like it's like this great voice and then
as doing it time and time again I
realized that Mitt Romney actually the
voice that I'm doing is basically when
black stand-ups do a white guy voice
they're doing like that boy like it hey
man how you do it buddy you know it's
like a place
Eddie Murphy would do like you know hey
buddy hey man
and I was like as I watched just do that
all the time and that's that's say you
know you were on Meet the Press exactly
yeah
and now a holiday is coming up you're
going back to you go back to Kansas City
yeah the city do you go back there for
the holidays I do I just was there for a
couple days for Thanksgiving and then
I'll go back for for Christmas and yeah
I'm gonna uh it's always fun I've
dabbled with staying in hotels i'vei've
but I think it's time to go back and
stay at home you know in my parents home
the same house my sisters and I grew up
in and my father's only gonna charge me
five grand a night he promises I'm
trying to talk him down if I do chores
but I will see if I get it down to 2,500
are they excited about you being in show
business are they kind of jaded about it
no I think they are excited if I get
when I go home I'm usually my mom has me
signed DVDs or like you know pictures
for clients he's a travel agent one of
the best in the biz and so I'll do that
and and you know you sign things for
their various charitable endeavors and
and yeah I know they're enthusiastic
it's very it's very sweet I was I was
very I was blessed to have parents they
were so supportive
it is sweet my mom I've told the story
before my mom used to go to the star
market Chestnut Hill which is right and
it were near where we live in Brookline
oh and when I was first on the air first
couple years of late night she would go
there and she would keep Late Night with
Conan O'Brien keychains in her purse
yeah and she would say to the cashier
like you like television okay you like
Connie he's alright
god bless it out
[Applause]